the last few months have seen remarkable
progress within the regeneration East
area a new BMX track has been designed
and built by Olympian Trent Jones and
construction is nearly complete with
final planting and grass to be
established before it opens for use
directly opposite the earthworks for the
sports fields are making good progress
and will soon be able to start on the
softball pitchers and changing room
facilities the stormwater management
area is also finished allowing the Honda
forest planting to get underway the
first community planting day was held in
late May with nearly 700 native trees
and shrubs dug into their new home the
surrounding 3.2 hectares will gradually
be restored to lowland pota carp forests
and interspersed with walking and
cycling paths and this has all been made
possible by the support of the Honda
tree fund this year as well we're
celebrating 30 years of being in New
Zealand and as part of that celebration
we've committed to planting 30,000 trees
in one year and the cry for regeneration
project is part of that clearly boughs
of trees we're really thrilled to be
part of it and we hope our customers
will come out and share in the forest
and health pardon me Oh David is
officially opened a Honda forest
alongside managing director of Honda New
Zealand noburo Sanada he says it was
pleasing to see former residents of the
area taking part I hope that they will
come back here in future years and say
well my piece of land contributed to do
something wonderful for carfully and for
one yridian indicator group and with
over 14 thousand trees yet to be planted
there will be plenty more opportunities
for the community to take part and the
restoration of this area
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]